a developer has turned a 1989 computer
into a bitcoin mining machine this is
absolutely wild here is the machine
itself from 1989 now this in back in the
day was a cutting-edge computer not
obviously anymore but this computer can
now mine bitcoin doesn't mind a lot but
this is a fascinating story because
ultimately what is gonna happen is every
single machine in the world is going to
be enabled to mine bitcoin what am i
talking about let's take this computer
right here here's the first photo we've
got a second one and then of course if
we actually go ahead and we look at this
antiquated piece of computing hardware
what the hell is it well this computer
is the toshiba t
3200
sx powered by a 16 megahertz intel 386
sx processor running on ms dos yes shout
out ms dos
when it first hit the market it was
available for about 6 300 or almost 14
000 in today's money so what the hell is
this thing doing mining bitcoin well if
you want to use this to mine bitcoin
it's gonna take you a long long time
you'll earn one dollar every 584
million years
one dollar every 584 million years
basically you don't earn that much but
the reason why i'm interested in this is
because every single computer every
single piece of hardware that is
internet enabled is going to end up
mining bitcoin think about your
microwave think about your refrigerator
think about the power port that's
actually in your garage for an electric
vehicle
anything that is connected to the
internet that is not actually consuming
power in the moment can be turned into a
cash flow generating asset your
microwave while it's not actually
microwaving anything could be used to
mine bitcoin same with your refrigerator
and same with every other asset you have
even your cell phone your watch smart on
your wrist every single thing could be
used to mine bitcoin now of course it's
not gonna mind a lot and that's okay but
imagine if now the hardware could become
a cash flowing asset that pays for
itself if i have something that's going
to last for 5 10 15 years it's got
enough computing power and it's also
internet enabled it can mine enough
bitcoin to pay for itself especially
when you incorporate in the future
appreciation of the digital currency it
becomes very interesting we've
previously talked about a guy who went
ahead and hacked this tesla was able to
mine bitcoin using his tesla there's no
difference between a tesla an old
antiquated computer your refrigerator
your microwave or any other piece of
hardware in your home even your
television one day will be able to mine
bitcoin ultimately what we are watching
is people around the world that consume
power are realizing bitcoin is a great
way to do load balancing to actually
offload energy into a battery which is
known as the bitcoin network and so
whether you're trying to do gas flare
capture at the actual oil field or
you're trying to hack an old antiquated
computer or you simply want to use the
smart devices inside your home
bitcoin now is a persistent consumer of
power and as people wake up to the idea
of the economic upside of mining bitcoin
i think every single piece of hardware
will become a bitcoin mining machine